[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Hello, Google Boston.
It's nice to be here.
Yes, I am in town
promoting my new book,
"The End of the End of the
World," a very scary seagull
on the cover.
And this is a weird one, the
belly of the beast for me.
I'm a long-credentialed tech
critic, going back, certainly
in print to 1995.
I've been hard on
Silicon Valley,
hard on some of the
dopey utopianism,
trying to call attention
to the intimate connection
from the beginning of
the commercial internet
between consumerism and tech.
And there is some stuff
about tech in the new book,
not so much in this book as
in some of the previous books,
but I'm going to
mostly focus on some
of the other preoccupations
in these new essays.
I'm going to read a
piece of one of them.
Let me first say that
it's a bit of a--
I was thinking on the way over
here, there are the big five,
and you guys are part
of one of the big five.
And it's been interesting
to trace almost
as a parlor game, which of
the five at any moment in time
has seemed to me the most evil.
For a long time, because
there weren't five,
there was really only
Microsoft, there was no contest.
I was a DOS user and then
a early Windows hater,
and there was much to dislike
about Bill Gates' company.
But then others quickly moved
in, beginning with Apple.
Apple was, for a
long time, easily
at the top of my most
hated list because
of its not so veiled contempt
for its passionate fans.
To me the absence of a
delete key on the keyboard,
on the famous Apple keyboard
is one striking example,
and I will not say more, but if
you're an actual writer having
a backspace key and a delete
key, it's a plus, believe me.
You don't need to
reposition the cursor.
You just hit Delete.
Sucks that character
right up from the right.
It's nice.
You'd think a large
company in the business
of helping academics and
writers might appreciate that,
but apparently it went
straight to Steve Jobs,
and he said no, the keyboard
is prettier without that.
So that was hateable.
And then there was that
wonderful series of ads,
and I actually came
to like Microsoft
because it wasn't
Apple, and Microsoft
was embodied by the
John Hodgman character
in the wonderful series of ads.
John Hodgman, totally
lovable, embodying everything
that had become weirdly lovable
about the formerly hated
Microsoft.
And what's his face?
Justin?
AUDIENCE: Justin Long.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Justin Long, yes.
I'm sure he's a nice guy, but--
[LAUGHTER]
So then, yeah, and I still--
my little tag at the bottom
of my Android Gmail account
showing that was
sent from a device
is still sent from
a non-Apple device,
because it does seem
very important always
to be stressing that.
But then Amazon, Facebook.
Amazon, one of the four
horsemen of the apocalypse
as far as the book industry
and bookstores are concerned.
Of course, it's gone beyond that
to become a textbook monopoly,
behaving in textbook
monopoly fashion,
and I think it really
occupied number
one on the most hated
list for many years,
and it still contents
for that spot.
But Facebook,
Facebook, Facebook.
I'm not mentioning
Twitter because it's not
one of the big five and
because it's not even clear
that it's worth hating.
It seems to me more like one
of those RNA viruses that
does unspeakable harm, but
people are not even sure
if it's a life form.
[LAUGHTER]
Whereas Facebook is
clearly a life form,
also scarcely behind Amazon
in its monopolistic intentions
and its monopolistic behavior.
And what seems really
particularly evil about it,
I mean, Bezos knows
what he's doing.
He knows it's bad, but
he kind of owns up to it.
It's not like he's
hiding the fact
that he wants to control all
consumer commerce everywhere
in the world, whereas
Facebook still
wraps it up in
these gauzy phrases
and seems just weirdly
immune to all of the harm
that it's causing with its
incredibly addictive product.
Its incredibly addictive,
surveillant, civil
discourse-destroying product.
So where is Google
in all of this,
I ask myself, riding the
old red line over here
from Harvard Square.
I lived in Somerville
for five years.
I wrote my first
novel while I was--
on the strength of
a research position
I had at Harvard in the
seismology lab there.
I lived in Somerville
for five years
and I am not sure I'd
been on a red line train
since I left in 1987.
So it was weird.
It seemed completely unchanged.
[LAUGHTER]
The buskers at the Harvard
Street Station were identical,
the trains looked identical.
It all seems sort of sadly
small, compared to New York.
That was identical, too.
Sweetly identical now.
At the time, it was sad,
even infuriatingly small.
That's why I moved to New York.
Anyway, I was
thinking why don't I
hate Google as much as I hate
Facebook and Amazon and even
Apple?
A large part of it
is because I really
like some of your products.
I am on Gmail and it's good.
I wish someone,
maybe afterwards,
can explain to me how to get,
on my Android device my emails
not to display in thread form,
so that when you delete one
you don't delete
the whole thread.
Maybe someone has some expertise
can help me configure that.
I searched and searched all
the settings, can't find it.
Anyway, but apart from
that, great product.
I use your search engine.
I use Google Maps,
that's all very good.
One could argue that Google's
position on copyright,
for a writer, ought
to give one pause,
but I kind of outsource that
outrage to the Authors Guild
that I'm a proud
member of, and let
it file the complaints
and even lawsuits
to try to protect poor writers
from the ever-widening net
sweeping up copyrighted
material and offering it
without compensation
to those writers.
So that's, you know,
it's a small thing.
But then--
AUDIENCE: Sorry to interrupt.
That's really not fair.
That's not an
accurate character--
JONATHAN FRANZEN: OK, I know.
It's-- I'm here to give you
the view how you are seen
in the writer's community.
It's true, that's-- and
indeed, this is in the context
of saying I don't hate
Google like I hate the others
because I find all sorts of
stuff with the Google search
engine, books that I would
otherwise not be able
to access, and it'll take me to
the keyword on page 267 of some
obscure text that was published
in 1953 or 1927, fantastic.
So I think we can
actually come to
some reasonable accommodation.
I do know that the
Authors Guild has
had some issues with Google.
But it's true, I
did, in my not so
accustomed to
public speaking way,
perhaps overstate the case.
Anyway, I was
thinking yesterday,
as I came in on
the plane, I travel
with stacks of New Yorkers
that I don't get around
to reading at home because
I can throw them away
and my bag gets lighter
and lighter as I travel.
And I happened to be
reading about Google
as I was landing in Boston
last night, the Levandowski,
that case, the Waymo thing.
And boy, does he sound
like not a great guy.
And it didn't affect the
standings at all, that piece.
It was a little hard
on Google and Waymo.
But I was thinking
about the whole notion
of the self-driving car.
The piece ends with
this wonderful quote
from Levandowski, talking about
how uninteresting history is,
how the only thing that
matters, at least to someone
in tech like him, is the future.
And I was thinking about
the self-driving car
thing, which was always
bugged me a little bit.
You
Make a list of problems we
have as a country, as a world,
and I struggle to imagine
that anyone, on their top 25
problems to be solved list has,
need to sit behind the wheel
while I listen to
podcasts and traffic,
rather than sitting
in the passenger seat,
listening to
podcasts and traffic.
It has always seemed to me that
perhaps the self-driving car
initiative has underestimated
the extent to which people
actually enjoy driving.
For Americans,
particularly, it's
an expression of
personal freedom.
In some ways, it's the,
for non-gun owners,
it's the expression
of personal freedom.
And then as I was taking a cab--
an old-fashioned cab, not an
Uber, from Logan last night--
because I think of
the poor cabbies
and like to support them
even though it would probably
have been cheaper to
take Uber or Lyft--
I was thinking about a problem
that's on everyone's list
that a lot of the tech oligarchs
seem suddenly very, very
preoccupied with, and
that's the problem of dying.
I think we can all agree that
that remains a big problem
for any human being.
You're going to die.
And it's a measure of the--
you want to know
why people like me
hold Silicon Valley
in such low esteem,
and why I personally have
watched all of the show
"Silicon Valley" at least twice,
every episode at least twice,
if not three times
or four times,
and think it's one of the most
profound cultural products
in the last eight years--
it has to do with this
notion that tech is going
to solve the problem of death.
And As we were whisking
in, wonderful now
to live in 2018
thanks to the Big Dig,
how quickly you can
get to your hotel--
it used to be an adventure to
get to Logan when I lived here,
before many of you were born--
I was imagining
being 635 years old
and wondering what I was going
to do this week and thinking,
maybe I will re-watch all
7,000 episodes of the Simpsons.
[LAUGHTER]
I haven't done that since I did
it as a special birthday treat
to myself the year I turned 500.
And it had been like a
couple of hundred years
since I'd watched even one
episode of The Simpsons
before then.
So it's like, I'm fresh.
It's been 135 years since I
watched all 7,000 episodes.
And I've got plenty of time
because I'm never going to die.
And also my options
for what I'm going
to do with myself otherwise
are rather limited,
because of course
I can't go outside.
Because what if some
freakish accident happened
and an enormous chunk of masonry
or a large tree fell on me
and obliterated 635
years' worth of living,
so damaged me that I couldn't
be put back together.
So basically I have to
wear these padded clothes
and this big spongy
helmet for fear
that something might happen to
me, because now I'm 635 years
and I can live forever,
thanks to technology,
but I have to be
very, very careful.
And also, for the first
480 years of my life
there was the risk that
when I would go outdoors,
I might run into a
mortal person, somebody
who didn't have as
much money as I did
and who was understandably
resentful that some people who
had a lot of money and could
afford it could be immortal
but they were not.
And that had become
such a problem,
with the rage of mortal people
against the wealthy immortal
people that finally
the decision had sadly
been taken to exterminate
all mortal people.
So that left just us immortals,
but we're still pretty bunkered
down because of the
risk of physical harm.
And what do you do?
You get married 30 times before
you're even 600 years old.
You keep your eye on that
cute little 180-year-old
down the hall, one of the
last people ever born.
Very, very attractive to
many of us older people.
And you know that in
the fullness of time,
because you'll live
forever, you'll
be able to marry that cute
little person down the hall.
And then divorce that person.
I've gone on too long
about the silly scenario.
I'm not a sci-fi writer, and
I'm sure sci-fi writers have
roasted the whole concept
much more than I. I'm not
considering the possibility
that our minds can
be downloaded and exist in
eternal form in digital form.
I could go into that, if I
had prepared more than riding
the subway over here, the
inextricability of identity
from bodily self.
It's merely to say that the
whole idea of living forever
doesn't pass the most
rudimentary moral examination.
And you have to think that
the tech billionaire who's
deciding to put $100
or $200 million dollars
into investigating the
possibility of living forever
is either unbelievably
morally stupid, or worse,
like, the worst kind
of asshole, imagining
that, well, other people have
to die but I don't have to die.
And that's kind of the
definition of an asshole.
So there's a gulf--
I've taken an extreme example--
but there is a gulf
between the way,
say, literature, considers
the problem of death
and the way problem-solvers
consider the problem of death.
Literature doesn't think
it's a solvable problem.
Much changes when
you acknowledge
that certain problems
aren't solvable, that people
are actually not very nice.
That's the great mistake
that the visionaries
made in the 90s.
They were all nice guys and most
of the people in the early days
of Facebook, they were all
well-educated, clean, happy
white people with
liberal politics.
What could the problem be?
Well, the problem is that
people aren't very good.
People are at least as
bad as they are good.
This is not, actually, a
solvable problem anymore
than death is.
So the approach I'm arguing
here with literature
is to accept the insolubility
of problems and say, well, then,
what then?
I'm going to die.
How do I position myself
in relation to that?
Start thinking about the fact,
well, other people I love
are going to die too.
In fact, everyone's
going to die.
Certain things fall
out that are actually
very positive in
terms of how you
lead your life in the moment
and how you treat other people
when you accept the reality and
the insolubility of a problem.
I began by saying
that most of the book
is not about this stuff.
A lot of it is about
nature and climate change.
And I'm going to read some
pages from an essay called
"The Essay In Dark Times".
Everything I ever write
is arguing for literature.
Even when I'm
writing about birds
I'm arguing for literature in
the way I write about birds.
Books are what I
most care about.
OK, so I've just
disrupted myself.
Where was I?
OK, I'm just going to
launch in and hopefully I
can make this comprehensible.
I'm starting right in
the middle of an essay.
When I came home from Africa--
where I'd been birdwatching--
to Santa Cruz--
this was two years ago exactly--
my progressive
friends were still
struggling to
understand how Trump
could have won I remembered
a public event I'd once
done with the optimistic
social media specialist Clay
Shirky, who'd recounted to
the audience how shocked
professional New York restaurant
critics had been when Zagat,
a crowdsourced
reviewing service,
had named Union Square Cafe
the best restaurant in town.
Shirky's point was that
professional critics
aren't as smart as
they think they are,
that, in fact, in
the age of big data,
critics are no longer
even necessary.
At the event, ignoring the
fact that Union Square Cafe
was my favorite New
York restaurant--
the crowd was right--
I'd sourly wondered if Shirky
believed that critics were also
stupid to consider Alice Munro
a better writer than James
Patterson.
But now Trump's victory, too,
had vindicated Shirky's mockery
of the pundits.
Social media had
allowed Trump to bypass
the critical establishment,
and just enough members
of the crowd in key swing
states had found his low comedy
and as incendiary speech
better than Clinton's
nuanced arguments and
her mastery of policy.
This follows from that.
Without Twitter and
Facebook, no Trump.
After the election
Mark Zuckerberg
did briefly seem to
take responsibility,
sort of, for having created
the platform of choice
for fake news about Clinton, and
to suggest that Facebook could
become more active in filtering
the news-- good luck with that.
Twitter, for its part,
kept its head down.
As Trump's tweeting
continued unabated,
what could Twitter possibly
say, that it was making
the world a better place?
In December my favorite Santa
Cruz radio station, KPIG,
began running a fake ad
offering counseling services
to addicts of Trump-hating
tweets and Facebook posts.
The following month, the week
before Trump's inauguration,
the PEN American
Center organized events
around the country to reject
the assault on free speech
that it claimed
Trump represented.
Although his administration's
travel restrictions
did later make it harder for
writers from Muslim countries
to have their voices heard
in the United States,
and although he did still later
kick Acosta out of the press
corps, the one bad
thing that could not
be said of Trump in January
was that he had in any way
curtailed free speech.
His lying, bullying tweets
were free speech on steroids.
PEN itself, just a
few years earlier,
had given a free
speech award to Twitter
for its self-publicized
role in the Arab Spring.
The actual result
of the Arab Spring
had been a retrenchment
of autocracy,
and Twitter had since revealed
itself in Trump's hands
to be a platform made
to order for autocracy,
but the ironies
didn't end there.
During the same week in January,
progressive American bookstores
and authors proposed a
boycott of Simon and Schuster
for the crime of
intending to publish
one book by the dismal
right wing provocateur Milo
Yiannopoulos.
The angriest of the
bookstores talked
of refusing to stop all
titles from S&S, including,
presumably, the books of Andrew
Solomon, the president of PEN.
The talk didn't end until
S&S voided its contract
with Yiannopoulos.
Trump and his
alt-right supporters
take pleasure in pushing the
buttons of the politically
correct, but it only works
because the buttons are there
to be pushed.
Students and activists
claiming the right
to not hear things
that upset them
and to shout down
ideas that offend them.
Intolerance particularly
flourishes online,
where measured
speech is punished
by not getting clicked on.
The invisible Facebook
and Google algorithm
steer you toward
content you agree with,
and non-conforming voices
stay silent for fear
of being flamed or
trolled or unfriended.
The result is a silo in which
whatever side you're on,
you feel absolutely right
to hate what you hate.
And here is another
way in which the essay
differs from superficially
similar kinds
of subjective speech.
The essay's roots
are in literature,
and literature at its best--
the work of Alice
Munro, for example--
invites you to ask whether
you might be somewhat wrong,
maybe entirely wrong,
and to imagine why
someone else might hate you.
I'm going to pause just to
say that I wrote this a year
and a half ago, and
it already feels
like what I was saying
then, which seemed urgent
and somewhat fresh, now a
lot of people are saying,
which has been very
heartening, particularly
the scrutiny of Facebook that
has unfolded in the past 18
months, has been
very, very heartening.
People are starting to get
it, as far as I can see.
Three years ago,
I was in a state
of rage about climate change.
The Republican
Party was continuing
to lie about the absence
of a scientific consensus
on climate, Florida's Department
of Environmental Protection
had gone so far as to forbid
its employees to write the words
climate change after the
governor, now involved
in an interesting
ballot recount,
insisted that it
wasn't a true fact.
But I wasn't much less
angry at the left.
I'd read a new book
by Naomi Klein,
"This Changes Everything",
in which she'd
assured the reader that
although time is tight,
we still have 10 years
to radically remake
the global economy and prevent
global temperatures from rising
by more than two degrees Celsius
by the end of the century.
Klein's optimism was
touching, but it, too,
was a kind of denialism.
Even before the
election of Donald Trump
there was no evidence to suggest
that humanity is capable--
politically,
psychologically, ethically,
economically-- of slashing
carbon emissions quickly
and deeply enough to
change everything.
Even the European Union,
which had taken the early lead
on climate and was fond
of lecturing other regions
on their irresponsibility,
needed only a recession in 2009
to shift its focus
to economic growth.
Barring a worldwide revolt
against free market capitalism
in the next 10 years, the
scenario that Klein contended
could still save us, the most
likely rise in temperature
this century is on the order
of six degrees Celsius.
We'll be lucky to avoid a two
degree rise before the year
2030.
Again, the new report in
October, starting to get it.
But this was three years ago.
Now, actually, four years ago.
In a polity ever
more starkly divided,
the truth about
global warming was
even less convenient to
the left than to the right.
The right's denials
were odious lies,
but at least they
were consistent
with a certain cold-eyed
political realism.
The left, having
excoriated the right
for its intellectual dishonesty
and turned climate denialism
into a political
rallying cry, was now
in an impossible position.
The left had to keep insisting
on the truth of climate science
while persisting in the fiction
that collective world action
could stave off the worst of it.
That universal
acceptance of the facts--
which really might have
changed everything in 1995--
could still change everything.
Otherwise, what
difference did it
make if the Republicans
quibbled with the science?
Because my sympathies
were with the left--
reducing carbon emissions
is vastly better than doing
nothing, every
half degree helps--
I also held it to
a higher standard.
Denying the dark
reality, pretending
that the Paris Accord
could avert catastrophe
was understandable as a tactic
to keep people motivated,
to reduce emissions,
to keep hope alive.
As a strategy, though, it
did more harm than good.
It ceded the
ethical high ground,
insulted the intelligence
of unpersuaded voters--
really, we still have 10 years--
and precluded frank discussion
of how the global community
should prepare for
drastic changes,
and how nations like
Bangladesh should
be compensated for what
nations like the United States
have done to them.
Now we get to one of my
main points in this book.
Dishonesty also
skewed priorities.
In the past 20 years, the
environmental movement
had become captive
to a single issue,
partly out of genuine
alarm, partly also
because foregrounding human
problems was politically less
risky, less elitist, than
talking about nature.
The big environmental
NGOs had all
invested their political capital
in fighting climate change,
a problem with a human face.
The NGO that particularly
enraged me as a bird lover
was the National
Audubon Society, once
an uncompromising
defender of birds, now
a lethargic institution with
a very large PR department.
In September 2014,
with much fanfare,
that PR department had
announced to the world
that climate change was
the number one threat
to the birds of North America.
The announcement was
both narrowly dishonest,
because its wording
didn't square
with the conclusions of
Audubon's own scientists,
and broadly dishonest,
because not one single bird
death could be
directly attributed
to human carbon emissions.
In 2014 the most serious
threats to American birds
were habitat loss
and outdoor cats.
By invoking the buzzword
of climate change,
Audubon got a lot of attention
in the liberal media.
Another point had been scored
against the science-denying
right, but it was not at all
clear how this helped birds.
The only practical effect
of Audubon's announcement,
it seemed to me, was
to discourage people
from addressing the real threats
to nature in the present.
I was so angry that I decided
I better write an essay.
I began with a jeremiad against
the National Audubon Society,
broadened it into a
scornful denunciation
of the environmental
movement generally, and then
started waking up in the
night in a panic of remorse
and doubt.
For the writer, an
essay is a mirror,
and I didn't what I
was seeing in this one.
Why was I excoriating
fellow liberals
when the denialists
were so much worse?
The prospect of climate change
was every bit as sickening
to me as to the groups
I was attacking.
With every additional
degree of global warming,
further hundreds of millions
of people around the world
would suffer.
Wasn't it worth
an all-out effort
to achieve a reduction of
even half of one degree?
Wasn't it obscene
to be talking about
birds when children in
Bangladesh were threatened?
Yes, the premise of
my essay was that we
have an ethical responsibility
to other species
as well as to our own, but
what if that premise was false?
And even if it was true,
did I really care personally
about biodiversity, or was I
just a privileged white guy who
liked to go birding?
And not even a pure-hearted
birder, a lister?
After three nights of doubting
my character and motives
I called my New Yorker
editor Henry Finder
and told him I couldn't
write the piece.
I'd done plenty of ranting
about climate to my friends
and to like-minded
conservationists,
but it was a lot like the
ranting that happens online
where you're protected by the
impromptu nature of the writing
and by the known friendliness
of your audience.
Trying to write a
finished thing, an essay,
had made me aware of the
sloppiness of my thinking,
and it also enormously
increased the risk
of shame, because the
writing wasn't casual
and because it was going out
to an audience of probably
hostile strangers.
Following Henry's
admonition, I'd
come to think of the essayist
as a firefighter, whose
job, while everyone else is
fleeing the flames of shame,
is to run straight into them.
But I had a lot more to fear now
than my mother's disapproval.
Sorry, that's going
over your head.
The first time I risked
shame in an essay,
my mother didn't speak
to me for a month.
My essay might have stayed
abandoned if I hadn't already
clicked the button
on Audubon's website,
affirming that yes,
I wanted to join it
in fighting climate change.
I'd only done this to
gather rhetorical ammunition
to use against
Audubon, but a deluge
of direct mail solicitations
had followed from that click.
I got at least eight
of them in six weeks,
all of them asking me
to give money, along
with a similar deluge
in my email inbox.
A few days after
speaking to Henry
I opened one of the
emails and found myself
looking at a picture of myself,
luckily, a flattering image,
taken in 2010 for Vogue
Magazine, which had dressed me
up better than I dressed
myself, and posed me
in a field with my
binoculars like a birder.
The headline of the email was
something like, join author
Jonathan Franzen in
supporting Audubon.
It was true that a few years
earlier in an interview
with Audubon Magazine
I had politely
praised the organization,
or at least its magazine,
but no one had asked
for my permission
to use my name and
image for solicitation.
I wasn't sure the
email was even legal.
So bad, really bad.
A more benign impetus to return
to the essay came from Henry.
As far as I know, Henry
couldn't care less about birds,
but he seemed to see
something in my argument
that our preoccupation
with future catastrophes
discourages us from tackling
solvable environmental problems
in the here and now.
In an email to me,
he gently suggested
that I lose the tone
of prophetic scorn.
This piece will be
more persuasive,
he wrote in another,
if, ironically, it's
more ambivalent
and less political.
You're not wailing on folks
who want us to pay attention
to climate change and
emissions reductions,
but you're attentive to the
costs, to what the discourse
pushes to the margins.
Email by email,
revision by revision,
Henry nudged me toward framing
the essay not as a denunciation
but as a question.
How do we find
meaning in our actions
when the world seems
to be coming to an end?
Much of the final
draft was devoted
to a pair of well-conceived
regional conservation
projects in Peru and Costa
Rica, where the world really
is being made a
better place, not
just for wild plants
and wild animals,
but for the Peruvians and
Costa Rican who live there.
Work on these projects
is personally meaningful
and the benefits are
immediate and tangible.
In writing about
the two projects,
I hope that one or two of the
big charitable foundations,
the ones spending tens
of millions of dollars
on biodiesel development or
on wind farms in Eritrea,
might read the piece
and consider investing
in work that produces results.
What I got instead was a missile
attack from the liberal silo.
I'm not on social
media, but my friends
reported that I was being called
all sorts of names, including
birdbrain and climate
change denier.
Tweet-sized snippets of my
essay retweeted out of context
made it sound as if I'd
proposed that we abandon
the effort to reduce
carbon emissions, which
was the position of the
Republican Party, which
by the polarizing logic
of online discourse,
made me a climate change denier.
In fact, I'm such a
climate science accepter
that I don't even bother
having hope for the ice caps.
All I denied was that a
right-thinking international
elite meeting in nice
hotels around the world
could stop them from melting.
This was my crime
against orthodoxy.
Climate now has such a lock
on the liberal imagination
that any attempt to
change the conversation,
even trying to change it to
the epic extinction event
that human beings
are already creating
without the help
of climate change,
amounts to an offense
against religion.
It's 1:40, I'm going
to just stop there.
The essay goes on.
Hopefully that was a
suspenseful point to stop.
I'd be happy to take any
questions you might have.
Thank you very
much for listening
to me this rainy afternoon.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
I have two questions,
actually, and apologies
if I didn't quite understand
some the points that you made.
My first question
is, given that the--
and probably I'm speaking on
behalf of the liberal orthodoxy
here--
but given that,
as you well know,
the climate catastrophe is
going to destroy all before it,
at some level what is the
point of focusing even
on sixth mass
extinction level events,
given that anything
that is preserved
is not likely to last more than
a couple of decades anyway?
And--
JONATHAN FRANZEN: Let's
have a back and forth.
I'll do that one,
and then you can--
if you remember your question
I'll go to the next one.
The short answer is I
know my spouse equivalent
Kathy is going to die.
What's the point in
doing anything with her?
trying to help her
in any way, given that she's
going to die pretty soon?
It's all going to be over.
Why would I--
At a certain level
the question doesn't
compute, because things I
love right in front of me
are in trouble.
I love them.
I want to help them.
I-- and yes, I know, it's going
to be tough for a lot of them.
Although birds are
shockingly resilient,
and there's some
recent new evidence,
one study in California showing
incredibly quick adaptation
in terms of when they
started the breeding cycle,
to a warming climate.
But that's not even--
it doesn't even matter.
The meaning in my life comes
from spending time with Kathy
and being around things I
love and trying to help them.
AUDIENCE: I guess it does,
at some level, come down
to a question of values, in
the sense that if your spouse
equivalent were going to--
I would not take an
action to prolong
her life by a minute or two.
I guess I would look at
the question of surviving
extinctions as best measured
in geologic time, where
it sounds like you're looking
at it at a human time scale.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Well, yeah, in terms
of meaning in what
I do with my life,
I have no choice but to view
it at a human time scale.
The thing is, we don't know
what the future holds exactly.
What we do know is if we let
the extinction event unfold,
there will not be anything.
We will have so radically
destroyed the fabric
of the natural world as
we were bequeathed it
that then, someone's coming
along with a blowtorch
after we've already
completely killed it.
But weird things happen.
Maybe the geoengineering
will fix things.
Maybe some-- even if it's
a relatively small fraction
of the species that make up
what we call biodiversity,
even managed to adapt,
evolve, it's like,
the more we've
got to start with,
the better chance everyone has.
So I don't see that
as necessarily--
I can also think in
a geological scale
as well about it, which is,
let's separate in our mind
what we're doing to the planet.
On the one hand we're destroying
the last remaining ecosystems.
On the other hand we're doing
this huge additional thing
that is going to make
everything really,
really, really terrible.
It's not that those are
actually two different things
we're doing.
And I'm saying one of
them is something--
and the latter, the
more terrible one
is something that we
apparently, by all appearances,
can't do anything about.
The former, well, in fact, there
are some very concrete things
we can do still.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK, that makes sense.
My second question,
you mentioned just now
that the latter is something
that we can't do anything
about, and earlier
in your talk you
spoke a little bit
disparagingly of the notion
that society might
have a all-out effort
to reduce the warming by,
say, half a degree Celsius.
I'm curious to what
extent do you see
climate change as a binary--
yes, the catastrophe
happens, or no, it doesn't--
and to what extent
do you see value
in reducing by some small amount
the scope of the catastrophe?
JONATHAN FRANZEN: Oh,
and the cameras rolling,
and so I really kind
of hate to admit
that I don't think there is
an appreciable difference
between 5.5 and 6
by the year 2100.
AUDIENCE: Do you see an
appreciable difference
in 800 million people dying
and 801 million people dying?
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Yes, of course, yes.
And if we could--
if there was some way to imagine
that collective action could
be taken on the part of
countries of the world
now and their populations
to save those,
even one million lives, I
would be all for doing it.
There are, of course,
other stakeholders.
And you get into these kind of--
the question is a
little bit like, well,
if here's the last pair
of elephants on earth
and here is a human
child, would you
let the baby die in order to
save the elephant species?
It's like, you can set these
things up and it's like, well,
who wants to admit
that they would
kill a human child in order to
save some non-human species?
The whole structure of
that kind of question
is morally upsetting.
But what exactly
is your question?
AUDIENCE: My question
is, is whether--
it sounds to me like you don't
see any moral value in reducing
the scope of the catastrophe?
Is that a correct understanding
of what you are arguing?
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
No, no, no, no.
I absolutely do.
If I thought we could really--
if we could prevent Bangladesh
from being submerged,
if there were some like--
even if it was a narrow
path to achieving that,
I would say we should
absolutely take that path.
AUDIENCE: Would you support--
and I recognize I'm going
on for a long time--
would you support a path
which would reduce by 10%
the fraction of Bangladesh
that is going to be submerged?
JONATHAN FRANZEN: That gets
us back into the, would you
save one child situation.
The real answer to
your question is
that 5.5, when it comes
to radical destabilization
of everything we consider
civilization, and certainly
everything we consider liberal
democracy and human rights
and the rule of law, you're
so far past the point
where it all breaks down that--
because remember, there will
be increasing numbers of people
who die simply
from being too hot.
So there is a direct--
summers will be
hotter, especially
in places like India and Africa.
People will simply
die of the heat.
But most but the
catastrophe we're facing
is a compounding
thing, where frequency
of extreme climatic events,
drought, water crises, all
of this begin to combine with
a political situation which
is deteriorating.
And then you throw
some gas on the flames
in terms of what technology
is doing to break down
the ability of people
to actually speak
to one another civilly and
come to some sort of agreement,
even about basic facts.
And it looks like what we've
got now, this lovely world here
in Cambridge, Massachusetts,
it's just really hard
to see how that stands
up, whether it's
5.5 or 6 degrees warming
by the end of the century.
Sorry to be a bummer about it,
but that's very good questions.
I appreciate the
opportunity to clarify.
AUDIENCE: Let's
move to literature.
Maybe it's less of an issue.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
[INAUDIBLE] has a question
is what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: In one of your
essays you mourn the fact
that readers think
and judge characters
in books in terms of
likability, how they like them.
I was wondering, how do
you feel about readers that
focus on assessing the
morality of characters,
and furthermore, as a writer,
are you concerned with how
readers can assess the
morality of your characters
in an ever-changing world
where the morality changed so
quickly, where one character
might seem to be quite
all right, but after a
few years you say, oh,
he's completely immoral, he
must be distanced from or even
banned completely.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
Yeah, I am a little
impatient with those
moral judgments.
I think people who go into
the business of writing
literary fiction tend to
be at odds with people who
are morally sure of themselves.
It's not quite an entry
level qualification
for being a good novelist,
but it's nearly one,
that you begin with
the presumption
that you don't know
what's right and probably
that what other people
consider right and wrong
needs some examination.
You know, it's interesting.
I take your question
partly be to be pointing,
in a little larger time
scale, toward the difference
in the way we read people
from the late 19th century.
Joseph Conrad, who was a
early and powerful critic
of colonialism.
That's how I
remembered "Nostromo".
It's just like this wipeout
attack on European colonialism
in South America.
I went back and I
reread "Victory",
which had been the novel of his
I admired most after "Nostromo"
last summer and it was like,
oh dude, you're such a racist,
you're such a sexist, you
don't understand women at all,
oh my god, that's--
what you are, ugh,
like, don't do that.
And the question is,
was that always there?
Because there are older
writers than that.
You go back to Shakespeare,
pick up "Macbeth" and--
I have no problem
with Shakespeare.
Yes, there's
anti-Semitism to be found,
and certain other somewhat
deplorable political aspects
of Shakespeare.
By and large, he's OK.
Tolstoy's OK.
Most of the women
fare much better,
although not all of them.
And to take a more
recent example,
a lot of the writing that was
so popular and so critically
privileged in the '60s.
"Catch-22".
"Catch-22" was this enormous
book for me, Joseph Heller.
It was my model for what I
wanted to do with my novels.
He was telling this crazy story.
It was funny and it was
line by line wonderful
and it was inventive
and it actually
seemed to do something
to change the world.
It was part of the cresting
of the anti-Vietnam War
movement in the late
'60s and early '70s.
Everybody was
reading "Catch-22".
That was my model of a book.
I go back and it's like,
oh dude, so sexist.
So sexist.
Would it have killed you
to do one female character
with her own subjectivity?
Apparently yes, not doable.
And Pynchon was the same way.
It's really-- actually,
even at the time
I knew Pynchon
was that way, when
I was reading "Gravity's
Rainbow" as a feminist in 1981,
it was like, ooh.
But there's other work
from the same time that
doesn't do that, which gets
into an argument I make
in this book, which is
that character is not just
characters on the
page, but there's also
the character of the writer.
And I think the stuff
that holds up well
is the writer has good
character, basically,
and you can make mistakes.
And yes, certain
cultural assumptions--
everyone was so racist in
the 19th century and before.
There's just no
way that you can--
it's almost impossible
to find a writer who
is completely free
of it, because there
was no penalty to be paid for
letting those attitudes show.
And yet within that
spectrum, some people,
you can say that person
had a big soul, big heart,
and that person,
bit of an asshole.
Anyway.
There was a sort of--
like you're at an auction nod
from the gentlemen in the back.
AUDIENCE: Curious how
you got into birding.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
I got into birding,
it was like any
religious experience.
I was converted by some friends.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was kind
of a Paul on the road
to Damascus moment
for me, and that was
seeing a veery in Central Park.
I had never heard of veeries.
There are 100,000 people in the
park, was a beautiful May day,
and here's this
bird, utterly lovely,
and one of the first
times I have ever
had binoculars in my
hand looking at it,
like, wow, that's
a beautiful thing.
And I'm surrounded by people.
What is this?
No one ever told me.
So yeah, it was people
taking me out and putting
binoculars in my hands.
It had been growing for a while,
but that was the main thing.
AUDIENCE: Being here at
Google, you kind of led us
into something that I've asked
myself here, working here,
and that is what would your
priorities for technology be?
Do you have a
vision for how could
a company with a big
social reach help
foster the kind of society
that we want to live in?
How do we connect
people without spreading
this ability for the platform
to be misused by people who
are spreading misinformation?
It turns out, from
what I see, it's
a technologically
difficult problem to solve.
JONATHAN FRANZEN:
It absolutely is.
I'd like to mostly slip
away with a promise
to go home and think about
that, because it's become--
I've been such a tech
critic for so long--
and not even a particularly
well-informed one,
just a kind of intuitive one,
which gets me into trouble
when I overstate my case.
But it's true that I perhaps
don't think enough about what
I wish it would look like.
There are so many--
I mean, first of all,
let's talk about-- there's
so many great things that you
guys do in terms of access
to information,
access to products.
I'm not a buying guy,
I'm not a consumer,
but every once in
a while there's
something hard to find
that I would like to find,
and Kathy, my spouse equivalent,
had some old dinner plates
and they were getting chipped
and we really liked them,
and I got them at Pier
One, like, in 1992.
And sure enough,
eBay, there they were.
I had to go through like
four different sellers,
but I was able to assemble
this what turned out to be--
I'm not sure if she
liked it-- but I
thought it was a
terrific birthday
present for her for a big
birthday she just had.
And-- small thing--
what it's doing just in terms
of accelerating certain kinds
of science,
particularly, science
with citizen participation.
It's fantastic.
I think email is a superior
form of communication.
I know it's gotten
out of hand, and I'm--
could go on and on and on.
I don't deny the blessing
the tech brings us.
I feel as if policy-wise, one
of the biggest problems we face
is that the DNA of Silicon
Valley is so anti-regulation,
it really comes out of a sort
of '60s and '70s hippie distrust
of the government, and that
has morphed, in many cases,
into something closer to a
right wing libertarianism.
But there's such hostility to
government, such deep distrust
of government, even as in terms
of power, reach, influence,
and wealth, the
industry has begun
to rival the government
in surveillant power
and in power to
shape public opinion.
Still there is such a deep
distrust of government
that it's just
almost unthinkable
to ask to be regulated, but
something like Facebook, to me,
cries out for regulation.
And something like
Amazon cries out
for quick antitrust work on the
part of the Justice Department.
There are things that
I think should happen,
and even though--
so it's on the one hand, the
part of the problem is a like,
in your bones resistance to any
form of government intervention
and distrust of government,
but also almost anything done
to impede what's
happening now is going
to have an effect on profits.
And Sherry Turkle
talks about something
that has begun to be discussed
a little bit in the social media
world, building in features
that encourage people
to disconnect rather
than to addictively
stay connected 60 hours a week.
Laughable idea,
because why would you--
why would you want to
reduce the stream of data
that your users are providing
as they remain online?
And yet even from like a
public health standpoint,
especially for
children, it seems
like you have to start doing
that, but it's going to cost.
And that's really,
really-- that to me,
is the real issue is that is
that Silicon Valley has become
a shareholder-serving operation.
And as long as--
so it's hard for me to--
I'm not even sure I would want
this, but it's hard for me
to imagine really radical
change without something
like nationalization, where it's
public ownership of at least
two or three of the big five,
treat them as public utilities,
and yeah, OK, and now there
are going to be certain rules,
and yes it's not going
to be as much money.
There's also not going to be as
much surveillance and so forth.
And I am going to stop after
uttering this sentence.
I think there are many ways
in which tech is already
a force for good, in that it
is fundamentally an information
business.
And information, if it's handled
right and used appropriately,
is a very powerful
and wonderful thing,
and that the main obstacle to it
becoming a true force for good
is that profit motive.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]